je vais aborder un sujet
d'actualité puisque le sait la
commission vient de publié ce matin un
rapport sur la réforme du corps
diplomatique qui a été engagée sous le
précédent quinquennat autant dire que
vous n'étiez pas en responsabilité
ministérielle et que ce que nous allons
pouvoir vous dire à ce sujet ne
s'adresse pas directement à vous sauf
que maintenant c'est vous la ministre de
l'europe et des affaires étrangères la
commission a déjà eu l'occasion de
s'exprimer sur cette réforme que très
globalement et à une très large majorité
nous rejetons dans son principe en effet
nous pensons que cette réforme du corps
diplomatique porte un risque pour la
pérennité de la diplomatie française le
maintien de notre capacité d' influence
il est difficilement compréhensible que
notre outil diplomatique dont
l'expertisé est admiré bien au-delà de
nos frontières et constituer une cible
prioritaire de réformes alors même que
le contexte international se dégrade de
jour en jour et j'y ajouterai que les
positions de la france sont
régulièrement fragilisé c'est pour cette
raison que la commission a désigné les
sénateurs jean pierre grand et andré
vallini pour travailler sur ce thème au
sujet duquel la commission a adopté la
semaine dernière très largement un
rapport d'information que
je me suis permis de vous adresser
nous prenons acte bien évidemment de
votre décision d'organiser une large
concertation sur les métiers de la
diplomatie mais vous conviendrez que les
décisions qui ont été prises ces
derniers mois doivent être remises à
plat et à tout le moins assorti d'un
certain nombre de clarifications et de
garanties qui ont été présentés ce matin
lors d'une conférence de presse par les
rapporteurs ils auront l'occasion d'y
revenir dans quelques instants pour ma
part je suis particulièrement attaché à
l'une de ces recommandations qui est en
quelque sorte une main tendue vers
l'exécutif elle consiste dans le fait de
permettre aux commissions compétentes
des assemblées parlementaires de donner
un avis sur la paire sur les
personnalités pressenties pour exercer
des fonctions diplomatiques d'une
importance toute particulière
cette recommandation s'adresse très bien
évidemment vos envahisseurs du g20 par
exemple en tous les cas des postes
absolument essentiel ainsi que ceux qui
sont exercées dans les grandes
organisations multilatérales
si une telle procédure ne peut
évidemment s'appliquer à l'ensemble de
nos ambassadeurs les responsabilités
exercées par nos ambassadeurs en europe
à pékin et washington où les
représentants permanents dans les
grandes organisations internationales
ont évidemment une importance qui
justifie de recueillir l'avis de la
représentation nationale ça se pratique
dans d'autres pays de manière tout à
fait fluide et à mon sens
7,7 permet cette proposition permettrait
à minima de rassurer nos diplomates et
d'apporter sur ce dossier un élément de
transparence démocratique sans toucher
bien évidemment au pouvoir de nomination
du président de la république car il est
hors de question de revenir sur un
pouvoir constitutionnellement exercer
depuis de longues années est donc bien
évidemment madame la ministre nous
serions très intéressé de connaître
votre position sur à la fois les
éléments que nous avons évoqués dans ce
rapport et ses différentes propositions
en deuxième lieu bien sûr la commission
souhaite vous entendre sur les leçons
que vous tirez sur le plan diplomatique
du déclenchement de la guerre en ukraine
en effet alors que l'union européenne a
déjà adopté six séries de sanctions
contre la russie et que la perspective
d'une guerre longue n'est pas écartée
vous nous direz quel est votre analyse
de la situation sur le plan politique y
at il quelques éléments qui permettent
d'espérer
ou de ne pas désespérer d'obtenir un
jour au moins un cessez le feu pour que
les drames humains que vous avez vous
même constater puisque vous êtes déjà
allés à deux reprises en ukraine pour
qu'il ne se prolonge pas ils ne fassent
pas souffrir inutilement la population
ukrainienne en particulier alors que le
conflit dure depuis bientôt cinq mois
est ce que vous pensez
compte tenu des informations que vous
avez qu'il existe un moyen terme des
perspectives de négociations entre les
belligérants et bien évidemment quel
rôle la diplomatie française entente
elle joué dans ces négociations
enfin au delà de la problématique des
livraisons d'armes à laquelle notre
commission est très attentif puisque
vous savez que nous exerçons aussi les
responsabilités de commission de la
défense vous nous donnerez des éléments
sur la situation humanitaire dans les
zones touchées par les combats et sur
l'action de la france pour financer et
acheminer une aide d'urgence à ces
populations
après votre prise de parole nous aurons
des échanges avec l'ensemble de nos
collègues qui j'imagine auront des
questions pour préciser nombre de points
j'imagine que certains auront aussi des
questions sur votre appréciation de la
situation chez plusieurs de nos pays de
nos voisins européens y compris dans les
pays où vous avez représenté la france
et plus particulièrement chez notre nos
chers amis britanniques que vous avez
quitté somme toute il ya assez peu de
assez peu de temps je rappelle que cette
audition fait l'objet d'une captation
vidéo et qu'elle est retransmise en
direct sur le site du sénat donc selon
là les habitudes de notre commission la
procédure jeu je vous propose de vous
exprimer prendre un quart d'heure vingt
minutes si vous le souhaitez en fait le
temps que vous souhaitez mais pour
laisser le temps après un échange qui
est toujours riche et nourris et que
votre prédécesseur estimer au plus haut
point merci madame la ministre vous avez
la parole
merci monsieur le président avec votre
autorisation je vais enlever mon masque
ce qui sera plus efficace pour vous
remercier monsieur le président alors
merci mesdames les sénatrices et
messieurs les sénateurs d'être là et
vous dire que je suis moi aussi
particulièrement heureuse de travailler
avec la commission des affaires
étrangères de la défense et des forces
armées du sénat
en saluant tout d'abord son président
non nous sommes déjà vu à quelques
reprises président mais non point dans
cette formation si c'est la deuxième
fois que je m'exprime au sénat depuis
que le président de la république et la
première ministre m'ont accordé leur
confiance et j'aurais réaffirmé devant
cette commission ce que j'ai pu dire
dans l'hémicycle comme mon prédécesseur
j'aurai à coeur d'entretenir avec vous
la relation de travail de la plus fluide
et la meilleure possible je vous
tiendrais naturellement régulièrement
informé des derniers développements sur
les dossiers prioritaires de politique
étrangère et je suis prête bien sûr un
débattre avec vous autant que nécessaire
et à vous rendre compte d'une façon
générale bien sûr de notre action
diplomatique
c est ce dont trou qui me connaissent au
faisait allusion au roman passé monsieur
le président
savent que je n'ai qu'une ambition agir
au service de la france et des français
et ce sera le cas dans ses nouvelles
fonctions je serai je l'espère une
interlocutrice ouverte à l'écouté est
toujours disposée au dialogue alors je
me réjouis de trouver ou de retrouver en
vous des interlocuteurs expérimenté des
interlocuteurs exigeons que je sais est
extrêmement attentif à l'actualité
internationale mais aussi à l'actualité
du ministère de l'europe et des affaires
étrangères particulièrement vigilant en
particulier quant aux moyens dont
dispose ce ministère et à l'exécution de
son budget nous aurons l'occasion d'y
revenir
j'en viens maintenant si vous me le
permettez comme vous m'avez invité à
quelques sujets que je voudrais aborder
avec vous à titre liminaire d'abord la
guerre en ukraine qui domine encore
largement l'agenda international
mais aussi notre agenda intérieur par
ses répercussions de tous ordres avant
de revenir sur quelques sujets
importants du moment où il y en aurait
beaucoup mais je voudrais prendre
quelques instants pour parler du sahel
et de l'iran si vous le permettez avant
de revenir sur les situations du
ministère
l'ukraine tout d'abord
la guerre
d'agression dans la russie s'est rendu
coupable contre l'ukraine 1 domine
largement notre agenda la russie a fait
le choix de ramener la guerre sur le
continent européen
en violant brutalement le droit
international en rompant l'ensemble de
ses propres engagements elle met
délibérément en cause les principes qui
régissent notre architecture de sécurité
collective depuis la fin de la seconde
guerre mondiale c'est une violation des
principes de la charte des nations unies
des principes fondamentaux du droit
international et également du droit
international humanitaire qui se déroule
sous nos yeux depuis le 24 février
il n'y a pas je dois le dire il n'y a
pas de justification possible aux
agissements dont la russie je le dis
clairement et seul coupable est seule
responsable
notre approche sur le sujet a toujours
été clair nous voulons mettre fin au
conflit sans devenir belligérants et
c'est la raison pour laquelle depuis le
24 février nous avons consenti des
efforts majeurs pour aider l'ukraine
pour l'aider à se défendre pour l'aider
à recouvrer sa souveraineté
alors qu'elle est depuis plusieurs mois
maintenant face à l'invasion russe je
voudrais rappeler les quatre piliers de
notre engagement
le premier c'est fournir à l'ukraine un
soutien politique diplomatique
humanitaire économique et financier
manifester notre solidarité aux
autorités comme au peuple ukrainien et
cela représente vous le savez mesdames
les sénatrices messieurs les sénateurs
un effort considérable à titre national
pour notre pays puisque nous en sommes
d'ores et déjà à 2 milliards d'euros
d'efforts nationale s'y ajoutent du côté
de l'union européenne l'union européenne
à laquelle nous contribuions une
assistance qui se montrent d'ores et
déjà également à 9 milliards d'euros
dont un déjà engagés
nous avons aussi participé parce qu'il
faudra penser à l'avenir à la confiance
de lugano début juillet le 5 juillet
conférence qui a permis de lancer une
coordination entre partenaires et de
poser quelques grands principes qui
devront régir la reconstruction de
l'ukraine la france et je veux citer la
non seulement l'état mais les
collectivités locales
concentrera ses efforts le moment venu
sur la région de chercher nive avec
laquelle les liens sont anciens
le soutien à l'ukraine cela se traduit
également vous l'avez en tête mais je
veux rappeler par cette décision
historique qui a été prise à l'unanimité
des 27 au conseil européen des 23 et 24
juin d'accorder le statut de pays
candidat à l'ukraine et à la moldavie
c'est une décision qui était
exceptionnel le chef de l'état l'a bien
dit à circonstance exceptionnelle
décision exceptionnelle
une décision qui était nécessaire pour
les peuples ukrainien et moldaves et une
décision nécessaire aussi je veux le
souligner pour notre propre sécurité
comme pour la stabilité du continent
européen
l'urgence commande d'arrimer ces pays à
l'europe sans attendre l'aboutissement
du processus d'adhésion qui ne dérogera
pas aux règles habituelles il n'y aura
pas de processus accéléré les critères
classiques devront être remplies et donc
nous voulons qu'il n'y ait pas de temps
d'attentes qu'il n'y ait pas de vide et
pensons engager dès à présent des
coopération concrets dans un certain
nombre de domaines on cite souvent
l'énergie les infrastructures
mais aussi la mobilité des jeunes
d'autres sujets peut-être dans le cadre
de cette initiative qui a été prise par
la france qui a été reprise par l'union
européenne et qui est celle de la
communauté politique européenne
s'adressant donc à l'ensemble des pays
européens par la géographie donc pas au
sens union européenne pays européens qui
candidat au nom candidats partagent les
mêmes valeurs démocratiques
une première réunion se tiendra sous
présidence tchèque qui a suivi la
présidence française de l'union
européenne à prague au mois d'octobre
le deuxième pilier de notre action c'est
apporter à l'ukraine un soutien matériel
et en particulier un soutien militaire
en lui fournissant des équipements y
compris les équipements les taux qui lui
permettent de se défendre qui lui
permettent de continuer à résister voire
de reprendre du terrain
j'étais hier à bruxelles pour un conseil
affaires étrangères avec mes homologues
européens donc et nous avons pris à ce
titre une décision importante qui est
d'augmenter la facilité européenne de
paix qui est l'instrument qui permet
de soutenir cet effort d'une nouvelle
tranche donc de 500 millions d'euros
pour aider les ukrainiens à tenir ce qui
porte à deux milliards et demi d'euros
l'assistance militaire de l'union
européenne en soutien à l'ukraine ce
pays a besoin de nous nous avons besoin
qu'ils tiennent et donc nous répondons
présents à titre national la france
prend toute sa part à cet effort
collectif
même signe nous soulignons moins que
d'autres ce que nous faisons pour des
raisons que chacun peut comprendre nous
avons fait le choix de ne pas
communiquer sur la totalité notre
contribution militaire et certainement
pas de la détailler ce sont des
informations dont tous les camps n'ont
pas besoin et que nous réservons à nos
partenaires européens alliés et surtout
un autre partenaire ukrainien chacun a
en tête par exemple les 12 canons caesar
255 d'ores et déjà livré et les six
autres dans le président de la
république a annoncé acquiesce le 16
juin la livraison prochaine et qui sont
en route je peux vous le dire ça n'est
qu'une illustration encore une fois nous
faisons beaucoup d'autres choses sur le
plan militaire
troisième pilier de l'action de la
france assurer une condamnation la plus
large possible au plan international des
agissements russe nous l'avons fait tout
de suite et nous avons déployé des
efforts considérables pour que aux
nations unies
grâce à deux votes à l'assemblée
générale des nations unies l'agression
de l'un d'eux s'y soient condamnés par
une très large majorité des états
membres de l'onu ce sont aussi les
efforts que nous déployons en soutien à
la cour pénale internationale
car il ne saurait y avoir d'impunité
pour les criminels de guerre et par
ailleurs et en complément de tout cela
l'union européenne et 43 pays bien sûr
donc la france un parmi ces pays ont
exprimé dans une déclaration le 13
juillet leur plein soutien aux démarches
engagées par l'ukraine devant la cour
internationale de justice autres voies
de droit contre l'agression menée par la
russie
quatrième pilier faire comprendre à la
russie qu'elle a choisi une impasse mais
aussi asphyxier progressivement le
financement son effort de guerre ce sont
les mesures restrictives qu'on appelle
plus communément sanctions et qui sont
des sanctions particulièrement massives
sans précédent je dois le dire qu'ils
sont mises en oeuvre depuis le début
février quarante huit heures après le
déclenchement de l'agression les
premières sanctions européennes ont été
adoptés nous avons adopté 6 e +1 de
réagir cette même si on le baptiste
ainsi paquet de sanctions avec nos
partenaires européens et avec nos alliés
nous avons renforcé ses sanctions encore
hier en adoptant
une interdiction
d'importation d'or en provenance de
russie ce qui va priver la russie de
plusieurs milliards d'euros de revenus
par an en réalité c'est presque 20
milliards d'exportations que la russie
faisait vers le reste du monde ça n'est
donc par une sanction mineure nous avons
aussi et ça c'est l'application d'une
décision qui a mis deux présents angers7
nous avons aussi toujours dans le droit
fil de ce qui avait été décidé par les
chefs d'état ou de gouvernement g7
renforcé des sanctions individuelles
pris des mesures restrictives
complémentaire contre certain nombre
d'individus
cinquante cinq individus de plus ont été
ciblés hier de plus et toujours à 27 est
toujours hier nous avons
renforcé les dispositifs européens
permettant de mieux lutter contre le
contournement des sanctions certains
dessins membre n'applique certains états
pardon non membre n'applique pas les
sanctions mais on a observé aussi par
ailleurs certains contournement des
sanctions et donc il fallait y mettre un
terme
tout ceci sera effectif après l'accord
politique obtenu hier dès cette semaine
sans doute dès demain par une décision
juridique formalisée au coreper dont le
message est clair nous luttons contre
tous ceux qui participent à l'effort de
guerre contre l'ukraine alors vous
l'avez dit monsieur le président notre
indépendance et donc notre sécurité à un
gros nous ne devons pour autant céder
devant aucun chantage et au contraire
nous mobilisons tous les leviers pour
priver vladimir poutine de larmes
énergétique ça exige au plan national
que nous fassions des efforts de
sobriété supplémentaires le gouvernement
en a déjà parlé il souhaitera donner
l'exemple à ce titre le président
républicain langlement précisé le 14
juillet ça suppose aussi que nous
réduisions encore la part des
hydrocarbures dans notre bouquet
énergétique au profit du nucléaire au
profit des énergies renouvelables mais
aussi suppose que nous continuions à
diversifier notre approvisionnement en
pétrole et en gaz comme nous le faisons
et enfin nous avons par ailleurs à un
dialogue avec les pays producteurs de
pétrole et de gaz pour les inciter à
produire davantage faute de quoi il
ferait le jeu de moscou
deuxième point nous devons face à ce
défi et ce défi lancé collectivement à
l'europe renforcer notre sécurité
collective
à cet égard nous avons obtenu plusieurs
avancées concrètes particulièrement
importante au moment du sommet de l'otan
à madrid fin juin je sais que vous avez
entendu tout récemment notre
représentante permanente auprès de
l'organisation de l'atlantique nord
marielle domna que vous a présenté ses
avances et donc je serais bref sur ce
point le temps que nous aurons un nouvel
échange dès jeudi je crois dans
l'hémicycle puisque vous aurez à vous
prononcer sur le projet de loi
autorisant la ratification des deux
protocoles d'adhésion de la suède et de
la finlande l alliance atlantique mais
permettez-moi souligné l'importance
politique de ces adhésions qui on était
là aussi
manifester au moment du sommet de madrid
cela va renforcer notre sécurité
collective va renforcer aussi notre
posture au sein de l'espace baltique et
renforcer enfin je veux souligner je ne
manque jamais de le souligner
la place des européens au sein de
l'alliance atlantique puisque nous
aurons si le parlement approuve deux
états européens de plus au sein
d'allianz ce sont donc deux bonnes
nouvelles bonne nouvelle pour l'europe
bonne nouvelle aussi pour notre temps et
notre sécurité collective et donc pour
la sécurité des français
dernier volet enfin notre réponse à
l'agression parce que cette crise prend
plusieurs formes et touche plusieurs
secteurs je vous évoquez la sécurité
alimentaire pendant des décennies depuis
les années 2000 depuis les objectifs de
développement du millénaire nous avons
réussi collectivement faire régresser le
nombre de pauvres dans le monde et faire
régresser la faim dans le monde
malheureusement
nous observons une rupture avec cette
tendance et les chiffres de la faim dans
le monde se dégrade désormais et se
dégrade notamment parce que la russie
applique en ukraine une stratégie dont
le cynisme est totale et qui les expose
au risque d'une crise alimentaire
croissante touchant de nombreux pays
dans le monde blocus de la mer noire
destruction des infrastructures
agricoles
ukrainienne en un mot
instrumentalisation d'une potentielle
famine et avec nos partenaires
europe et internationaux à l'onu à l'om
c'est et au g7 où se mobiliser une
manoeuvre est en cours peut être aboutir
at elle demain mais nous sommes encore
circonspects sous les auspices des
nations unies pour trouver un accord
entre eux nations unies russie ukraine
turquie afin de trouver des solutions
pour reprendre l'exportation des
céréales via la mer noire sachant que
les exportations de céréales existe par
le continent par voie routière
ferroviaire official mais ne suffisent
pas à emporter les quantités qui serait
nécessaire donc nous verrons si cela
peut aboutir et se concrétiser demain je
reste prudente tant nous avons vu ces
dernières semaines la russie a ajouté
quelques conditions chaque fois que une
étape était franchie et puis je veux
rappeler à ce titre que nous avons mis à
profit notre présidence du conseil de
l'union européenne pour lancer entre
européens une initiative qui est la
mission pour la résilience alimentaires
et agricoles mieux connue sous son
acronyme en anglais farm
qui vise à relever trois défis dans
cette initiative est reprise désormais
par l'union européenne pour relever
trois défis la libre circulation des
denrées ce qui requiert la transparence
des marchés agricoles et l'interdiction
la prohibition de toute restrictions aux
exportations on avait vu certains pays
adopter des mesures restrictives et nous
sommes passés par le canal de l'om c'est
pour avancer
deuxièmement la solidarité renforcée
envers les pays les plus vulnérables
nouvelles sont par le pam a pour les
aider davantage il présente la
république a pu annoncer vous vous en
souvenez le doublement de la
contribution de la france au programme
alimentaire mondial et troisième pilier
l'accroissement des capacités de
production agricole et alimentaire dans
les pays du sud des productions qui
doivent être plus durable et plus
résiliente notamment bien sûr en afrique
nous nous appuyons pour cela sur le fida
et enfin sur ce volet parce que nous
avons voulu et réussit à le mobiliser le
secteur privé peut et doit aussi
apporter sa contribution cet effort de
solidarité nous avons réuni avec marc
fesneau ministre de l'agriculture donc
sous l'égide
de la france 17 entreprises qui ne sont
pas uniquement des entreprises
françaises mais aussi des entreprises
africaines européennes
ou internationales qui représentait
l'immense majorité du secteur du négoce
pour que elles forment elles l'ont fait
donc le 23 juin une coalition mondiale
du secteur privé pour la sécurité
alimentaire qui va apporter sa propre
contribution concrète par la fourniture
des espaces de stockage par la
fourniture de matériel roulant toute une
série dispositifs qui sont mieux à même
que les états d'apporter avec comme
point d'étape un rendez vous qui a
d'ores et déjà été fixé en septembre en
marge de la prochaine assemblée générale
des nations unies c'est une action en
complément de celles des états qui est
forte utile
je veux évoquer brièvement la situation
en afrique et
particulièrement au sahel parce que je
reviens d'un déplacement effectué au
niger avec le ministre désormais nous
avons effectué ce déplacement sébastien
lecornu et et moi même à la demande du
président de la république
au niger pour discuter avec les
autorités de ce pays de nos coopérations
futures dans tous les domaines et pas
seulement dans le domaine de la sécurité
de la défense puisque notre coopération
ne ne doit pas avoir ce seul
âge mais avoir aussi le visage du
partenariat que nous appelons de nos
voeux de l'aide au développement de la
formation d'éducation et de l'aide
humanitaire j'ai d'ailleurs pu signer
quelques accords à ce titre et j'en ai
été forte heureuse en amour et pour
informer votre commission il était
frappant de constater que nos homologues
nigérien et en particulier
leurs présidents le présent bazoum se
sont montrés très inquiet pour la
sécurité de leur pays
surtout après le retrait de barkan du
mali mais nous ne pouvions plus rester
mais pas seulement pas seulement les
menaces sont nombreuses sur plusieurs de
leurs frontières ils nous ont demandé de
rester engagés militairement alors que
tu es et je veux rappeler que
l'opération
qui contribuent sous l'autorité sous le
commandement des forces armées
nigériennes à chasser les groupes
terroristes armés s'effectue bien sous
le commandement des forces nigériennes
suite l'expression des besoins que nous
avons entendu la semaine dernière nous
allons établir une feuille de route et
définir au mieux les modalités de notre
partenariat dans les semaines qui
viennent l'objectif vous l'avez
peut-être vu et de pouvoir aboutir en
septembre à une feuille de route agréé
par les uns et les autres que nous
présenterions à nos plus hautes
autorités à ce moment là et nous
cherchons
associé aussi nos partenaires européens
les autorités du niger en forme et
publiquement le voeu que quelques pays
européens puissent poursuivre la région
certains d'entre eux sont déjà présents
pour de la formation mais au delà de la
formation pour contribuer à ce que nous
essayons de faire ensemble et après
avoir évoqué très brièvement le niger je
voudrais revenir sur la situation au
mali puis ce que j'évoquais le lard et
articulations de notre dispositif
le président de la république vous savez
a dû décider au mois de février il a
fait en accord avec nos partenaires
européens et en accord avec nos
partenaires africains a dû décider de
retirer nos forces nous étions présents
au mali à la demande des autorités du
mali dès lors que les nouvelles
autorités issues d'un double coup d'état
ne souhaitait plus la présence française
il fallait en tenir compte
retirer nos forces ce retrait est en
cours il se déroule convenablement il se
déroule selon le calendrier prévu je
veux dire par là que nous devrions avoir
achevé à la fin de l'été c'est un choix
bien sûr qui marque un tournant qui aura
des conséquences
mais je veux ajouter que pour autant
nous n'avons pas abandonné notre action
au sel je parlais du niger mais y aurait
d'autres exemples et pour ce qui
concerne le mali nous maintenons notre
pression nous avons suspendu tous nos
financements tous les financements qui
transitent par les autorités maliennes
ont été suspendus seuls les financements
humanitaire qui vont directement à des
projets le développement et dont nous
sommes certains qu'ils bénéficient
exclusivement aux populations et à ce
projet ont été maintenues la plupart des
bailleurs internationaux d'ailleurs on
fait de même il y avait trop de
détournement et donc il fallait
recentrer tout notre aide nous l'avons
fait le dernier élément sur ce difficile
dossier et que le 3 juillet
l'organisation régionale qui est la
cedeao a décidé à la fois d'un
calendrier de la transition pour le
retour vers des élections et d'une levée
partielle des sanctions
le mali reste exclue de l'organisation
des engagements ont été pris dont il
faudra que les membres de la cdo vérifie
qu'ils sont bien tenues étape par étape
comme prévu dans leurs accords et les
sanctions économiques et financières
commerciales
si elles ont été levées ne signifie pas
que toutes les sanctions des partenaires
africains du mali ont été levées les
sanctions individuelles demeurent elle
vise 150 personnalités bien sûr cible
essentiellement la junte et je rappelle
évidemment ça va de soi que la france et
l'union européenne en pour leur part
maintenus les sanctions qui avait été
adoptée après les coups d'état au-delà
de ça vous avez entendu le président de
la république vous avez entendu madame
la première ministre pendant sa
déclaration de politique générale la
france fait renouveler en profondeur sa
relation à l'afrique notamment en
s'adressant désormais davantage à la
jeunesse africaine en s'empressant
davantage aux sociétés civiles dans le
droit fil
de la politique qui avait exposé
présenté exposé en détail le présent de
la république dans son discours de
ouagadougou de 2017 mais aussi dans ce
que nous avons fait avec la société
civile africaine lors du sommet afrique
france de montpellier
en 2021 et à ce titre nous travaillons à
deux chantiers concrets en particulier
je veux citer une maison des mondes
africains
en france qui sera un lieu de référence
pour la création contemporaine sera pas
un musée que nous ambitionnons de fermer
un lieu de création et puis un fonds
d'innovation pour la démocratie pour
soutenir des projets concrets pour
soutenir la recherche aussi dans ce
domaine sur le continent africain
je termine en rappelant que nous nous
sommes
seuls à nous soucier de
des différentes situations difficiles
qui se présentent en afrique et de la
situation de l'afrique en règle générale
nous avons convaincu nos partenaires
européens de la nécessité de s'impliquer
car il en va bien évidemment aussi de la
sécurité des autres pays européens et
pas seulement de la france nous avons pu
sous notre présidence française du
conseil de l'union européenne
en février dernier réunira sommet union
européenne union africaine c'était une
étape importante de la refondation et de
lure paix anisation si je puis dire de
ce partenariat de continent en continent
qui me semble indispensable dans tous
les domaines et pas seulement dans le
domaine de la sécurité
quelques mots sur l'iran sans trop
prolongé ses propos liminaires monsieur
le président parce que la situation est
extrêmement grave
également et parce que le temps est
compté
pour résumer à un dossier qui dure
depuis de très longues années
et des négociations qui durent depuis de
très longues années également un accord
avait pratiquement été conclu entre
négociateurs au mois de mars dernier et
donc sur la table c'est ce qu'on appelle
le
l'accord qui permettrait le retour au
jeep i see you et
qui est le résultat de très longues et
difficiles négociations
d'année en réalité d'efforts
diplomatiques avec nos partenaires du
pétrole et avec l'union européenne
nous avons été motivée par une
conviction forte qui est que l'accession
de l'iran
au nucléaire militaire créerez
évidemment une véritable crise régional
des pays de la région avec lesquels nous
entretenons ce particulièrement inquiet
de cette perspective mais ça mettrait
aussi en danger le régime de non
prolifération dans le monde et accroître
et
vraisemblablement aussi le risque d'un
potentiel conflit nucléaire toutes
choses que nous ne devons pas voir
arriver
al'inverse le retour de l'iran jpy sio
et permettrait à ce pays de sortir de l'
isolement politique mais aussi
d'isolement économique avec un mécanisme
de levée progressive et contrôlée des
sanctions et répondre et j'en suis
convaincu également aux aspirations de
la population iranienne qui ne trouvent
pas toujours s'exprimer puisque les
processus de décision sont
particulièrement opaques dans ce pays ce
que je voulais vous dire c'est que nous
sommes près du moment où il n'y aura
plus de retour en arrière possible nous
avons fait beaucoup d'efforts nous avons
fait preuve d'une très grande patience
mais la situation actuelle n'est plus
tenable
lire on multiplie les processus
dilatoires et on connaît son talent à le
faire il poursuit le démantèlement des
dispositifs de suivi de la ya donc les
activités nucléaires de l'iran ne sont
plus contrôlés comme elle devrait l'être
et donc nous n'avons pas les
vérifications qui devrait être faite
tout récemment au mois de juin nous
avions réussi à ré engager des
négociations
certes indirecte mais des négociations
entre iraniens et américains mais aussi
son qui se sont tenues à dos et qui ont
été malheureusement marquée par un recul
dans les positions iraniennes qui
demande une série de choses nouvelles et
parallèlement à tout ça parallèlement le
programme nucléaire iranien continue de
se développer
c'est une situation grave un accord
permettrait de retarder il ne serait pas
miraculeux sans doute et ne résoudrait
pas tous les problèmes régionaux mais il
permettrait de retarder de retarder
significativement
le franchissement par les rangs du seuil
nucléaire qui serait gravissime le jpy
seo et conserve un intérêt
chaque jour un peu moins où pourrait-on
dire puisque l'iran poursuit ses progrès
et se rapproche du seuil nucléaire mais
nous sommes convaincus qu'il y à un
espace qui reste ouvert pour peu de
temps et nous disons à l'iran je les
fais moi-même auprès de mon collègue
ministre des affaires étrangères de la
république islamique d'iran que le temps
est compté nous lui disons qu'il n'y
aura pas de meilleurs accords sur la
table aucun autre corps ne sera négociée
chacun peut comprendre par ailleurs que
les perspectives des élections de mi
mandat aux états unis d'amérique ne
permettront pas aux états unis de faire
d'autres pas quand bien même il le
voudrait donc le messager est simple
l'iran ferait une grave erreur en
pensant qu'il pourra obtenir un meilleur
accord ça n'est pas le cas et s'il
attendait il n'y aura tout simplement
plus d'accord sur la table
je vous évoquez monsieur président
mesdames et messieurs les sénatrices et
sénateurs
puisque vous l'avez fait président mais
j'y reviendrai certainement plus en
détail dans les questions la situation
qui est celle du ministère de l'europe
et des affaires étrangères
vous avez consacré de récents travaux
vous avez consacré une conférence de
presse ce matin
alors vous le savez et ça n'est pas
événement banal parce que je crois que
notre maison n'est pas coutumière des
mouvements de grève c'est le moins qu'on
puisse dire le quai d'orsay a connu un
mouvement de grève le 2 juin dernier
c'est une mobilisation qui est
inhabituel dont je mesure toute la
portée et dante au delà de moi le
gouvernement mesure toute la portée elle
est évidemment
révélatrices d'un malaise et de malaise
qui touche notre administration centrale
comme nos postes à l'étranger mais
révélatrice
je le crois profondément au delà de ce
malaise
d'un décalage croissant au fil des
années
dirais-je même au fil des dizaines
d'années qui ont vu les missions
confiées à ce ministère être toujours
plus nombreuses parce qu'un certain
nombre de questions globales n'existait
pas tout simplement une génération parce
que nous ne nous occupons pas de la
pandémie comme nous l'avons fait depuis
deux ans parce que les négociations
climatiques ont pris de l'importance
parce que le thème de la biodiversité
n'a été introduit que récemment dans la
vie internationale sous l'égide de la
france d'ailleurs dont les missions sont
sans cesse croissante les besoins de nos
compatriotes à l'étranger demeure et
face à cela les moyens budgétaires les
moyens humains jusqu'au coup d'arrêt que
grâce à la représentation nationale mon
prédécesseur jean yves le drian et je
veux à la fois remercier leur
représentation nationale et rendre
hommage à jean yves le drian permet de
donner un coup d'arrêt mais un coup
d'arrêt qui ne permet pas de remonter ce
que nous avions perdu au fil des années
c'est cela je pense le sens du mouvement
les agents de ce ministère en ministère
auquel j'ai consacré l'essentiel de ma
vie professionnelle auquel j'étais vous
l'essentiel de mon activité
plus qu'à plein temps depuis maintenant
deux mois ce sont des gens qui ont le
sens du service public ils l'ont
chevillée au corps c'est un engagement
que de servir le mystère de l'europe et
des affaires étrangères ils l'ont montré
d'ailleurs ils l'ont montré depuis deux
ans avec la pandémie
faire revenir des français qui étaient à
l'étranger me permets tu n'es pas à
revenir les hanter des centaines de
milliers vous le savez leur fournir des
vaccins lorsqu'ils n'en avaient pas
évacuer nos compatriotes d'afghanistan
les évacués d'ukraine plus récemment et
donc je veux vous vous remercier
monsieur le président mesdames et
messieurs les sénateurs qui avaient fait
ce rapport
vous avez
parfaitement dit que servir cette maison
c'est à voir l'engagement d'une vie
les agents du ministère ils sont très
sensibles
je le suis aussi alors dans ce contexte
qui ne tient pas qu'à une réforme mais
qui tient
cette prise en tenaille désormais entre
nos moyens et et nos missions il m'est
apparu fondamental de réagir y compris à
mon niveau donc j'ai écouté tout de
suite les agents
et renouer le dialogue je poursuivrai je
me suis entretenu avec les organisations
syndicales bien évidemment elles sont
représentatives mais aussi avec les
représentants des grévistes je les ai
reçus dès le 7 juin donc au lendemain de
la grève mais j'ai aussi profité de la
tenue du comité technique ministériel du
1er semestre pour poursuivre le dialogue
et la concertation
le 21 juin
et ce dialogue si on veut qu'il
fonctionne il faut le poursuivre en
travaillant dans trois directions
mettre en oeuvre la réforme de la haute
fonction publique au quai d'orsay ce une
réforme de la haute fonction publique
qui a été fait et qui ne singularise pas
le quai d'orsay
notre maison pense à elle c'est bien
normal mais elle n'est pas singularisé
et je me suis employé à le lui dire il
faut donc expliquer mieux
expliquer mieux la réforme explique
aussi ce qu'elle représente
d'opportunités car c'est le cas il y a
également des opportunités pour les
agents et expliquer mieux détailler
mieux les garanties qu'ils ont été
obtenus par mon prédécesseur jean yves
le drian sur un certain nombre de sujets
qui sont des sujets importants
structurant pour notre diplomatie les
concours les carrières le droit d'option
le pouvoir de nomination
souvent ces garanties sont un peu
passées sous silence ou ne sont pas
appréciés à hauteur de ce qu'elle
représente parce qu'aucun autre
ministère n'a obtenu de telles garanties
et il ya eu pour tout vous dire monsieur
le président mesdames les sénatrices
messieurs les sénateurs également
quelques contre vérités
la mise en extinction des deux corps des
ministres et de conseiller des affaires
étrangères ne signifie pas l'extinction
des métiers et ne signifie pas
l'extinction des carrières nous avons
obtenu au contraire jean yves le drian a
obtenu que les agents qui servent ce
ministère puisse continuer d'y exercer
leur carrière tout le temps s'ils le
souhaitent nous avons aussi
maintenu le concours d'orient il sera
donc possible et c'était nécessaire de
recruter des spécialistes de zones
sensibles j'ai évoqué quelques uns des
dossiers qui nous occupe et qui trouble
la vie internationale on voit bien que
ces spécialités reste tout à fait
indispensable et puis
d'une façon générale avoir des
compétences multiples avoir des agents
aux talents divers ça fait partie de ce
qui fait la force de notre diplomatie
vous avez bien voulu me rappelait le
président qu'elle était une des
meilleures au monde
la deuxième direction
et nous allons avoir notre discussion
budgétaire bientôt c'est qu'il faut
réarmer ce ministère en termes
budgétaires et surtout en termes
d'emploi l'enjeu est capital on pourra
citer des tas de chiffres dans nos
conversations avec le mystère du budget
avec un certain nombre de nos collègues
avec la première miss euro même parfois
avec le président de la république
chacun peut trouver des chiffres à
l'appui de sa démonstration
mais je ne retiendrais qu'un en 15 ans
et à périmètre constant
c'est important parce que les évolutions
des périmètres donc dans le passé
peuvent conduire à des effets d'optique
fashion à périmètre constant ce
ministère a perdu plus de 18% de ses
effectifs
alors que les effectifs de l'état resté
globalement stable
-1 18% de ses effectifs comment les
agents de mon ministère pourrait-il
assurer des fonctions plus nombreuses
plus importante plus critique souvent
avec tant de personnel en moins
ils l'ont fait et encore une fois il
faut leur rendre hommage parce que nous
avons assurer ce service y compris dans
les crises et chaque fois qu'il le
fallait et vous voyez que le
comportement diplomate est exemplaire et
des agents même lorsqu'ils ne sont pas
diplomates sont exemplaires
mais d'autres ministères n'ont pas fait
cet effort d'autres même et je voudrais
rappeler que nous sommes un mystère dits
régaliens je prends des points de
comparaison avec les ministères
régaliens ont vu leurs moyens et leurs
effectifs augmenter les armes et l'ont
fait et c'était nécessaire la justice
l'a fait et c'était nécessaire la dgse
l'a fait et c'était nécessaire pour
trouver d'autres et blanc nous avons ces
années après années des efforts tels que
ça nous amène aujourd'hui à la situation
vous avez souligné à la situation qui
l'objet d'autres rapports et qu'il faut
dépasser en sortant par le haut comme on
dit en suivant les trois directions que
j'en recommande satiété la deuxième elle
est importante et j'espère que dans la
discussion budgétaire qui s'annonce je
pourrai compter sur la bienveillance et
même sur l'appui de la représenter
sûrement
une nouvelle crise pendant le s'ouvre
troisième direction merci beaucoup et
manuel vous en avez entendu parler
puisque vous êtes en contact avec les
agents de notre mystère et en
particulier avec les agents qui ont fait
grève qui se sont exprimés
les assises où les états généraux de la
diplomatie c'est une idée que j'ai fait
mienne qu'il faut maintenant que nous
mettions en oeuvre parce qu'il faut
réfléchir au delà de
la technique la consolidation des
garanties aux au delà des questions de
budget d'emploi il faut réfléchir à
l'outil diplomatique dont la france et
les français ont besoin dans le monde
d'aujourd'hui le dernier livre blanc
remonte à 2008 je me souviens d'avoir eu
l'honneur de participer au travail qui a
été fait par le ministère sous l'égide
d'alain juppé de louis schweitzer 2008
c'est déjà un peu loin derrière nous le
monde a beaucoup changé et pour tout
tient il ne s'est pas simplifié et je
pense que cet exercice non seulement
serait nécessaire compte tenu du malaise
qui s'est exprimée le 2 juin ou même
avant le 2 juin et traduit par cette
grève de deux heures mais il est
indispensable et salutaire il est
nécessaire pour nous tous je voudrais
vous dire que nous aurons dans cet
exercice besoin de votre regard besoin
de votre approche et donc je serais
heureuse de vous consulter de vous
associer à ce travail de fond si vous
souhaitez vous même être partie prenante
sur le point particulier
des dunes des propositions que vous avez
fait est que vous avez évoqué en
introduction monsieur le président tout
en précisant que je n'ai pas pu encore
prendre connaissance aujourd'hui de
votre rapport qui est celui d'un avis
que donnerait ou que pourrait donner les
commissions des affaires étrangères de
la défense et des forces armées pour ce
qui concerne le sénat des deux
assemblées sur les nominations
d'ambassadeurs
je prends note de votre proposition je
vous en remercie elle posera avant même
toute réflexion sur une question
d'opportunité elle posera une question
de faisabilité juridique j'aurai donc
besoin de l'expertisé dans le détail et
je me propose de revenir vers vaut bien
évidemment compter sur moi je le ferai
voilà mesdames les sénatrices et
sénateurs monsieur le président je veux
saluer la contribution qui est la vôtre
au travail diplomatique de la france une
contribution toujours amicales exigeante
vigilante comme il se doit je compte
bien poursuivre en confiance ce travail
avec vous merci des surprises merci
madame la ministre merci de ces
premières analyses à la fois sur la
situation internationale et en réponse
au travail que nous faisons de faire sur
un corps diplomatique
l'avons dit à plusieurs reprises notre
volonté et je pense que c'est évidemment
la vôtre c'est de vous donner bien
évidemment les moyens d'assumer les les
missions qui vous sont confiées
sans plus attendre ce que j'ai dit ce
très impressionnante de le coller qui
veulent intervenir donc j'ai déjà donné
par lens andré vallini et qui est
rapporté sur lampy après on va essayer
de concentrer un peu nos pensées de ne
pas arriver nous nous prenons les noms
nous prenons les nonces aller allons-y
andré merci monsieur le président madame
la ministre vous êtes une diplomate
chevronné vous avez servi dans des
postes prestigieux rome à londres vous
avez été déjà au gouvernement chargé des
affaires européennes et vous savez mieux
que quiconque que la voix de la france
est attendu sur la scène internationale
que son rôle n'est pas n'importe quel
rôle et que pour jouer ce rôle la france
a besoin de diplomates professionnels
aguerris et expérimentés
j'ajoute et vous l'avez laissé entendre
d'ailleurs qu'être diplomate correspond
souvent une vocation qu'on a ces jeunes
dès l'adolescence et je suis frappé mois
depuis je m'occupe tout affaires
internationales comme mes collègues de
voir avec l'appoint les diplomates
aiment leur métier qu'ils n'ont jamais
envisagé d'en faire un autre alors à
partir de là vous l'avez dit vous-même
cette réforme n'est pas comprise elle
est même rejeté par les personnels du
quai d'orsay
on avance parfois l'argument pour
défendre la réforme qu'elle serait
nécessaire pour ouvrir le corps pour
sortir de l'entretoit au rejet des
chiffres qui montrent qu' il n'ya pas
d'entre eux soit que le corps est déjà
ouvert 20% de l'encadrement n'est pas
issu du corps diplomatique au quai
d'orsay et en 2010 9 19% des emprunts
ambassadeurs étaient occupés par les
personnes en détachement ou intégrés au
mae donc cette réforme est inutile pour
sortir de l'entretoit il n'existe pas et
puis surtout elle est dangereuse la
prison cambon l'a dit tout à l'heure
les crises se succèdent
il ya la guerre en ukraine les défis
migratoires climatiques économiques sont
nombreux et face à tous ces défis nous
avons besoin d'une véritable diplomatie
professionnels or avec la réforme dont
nous parlons qui peut garantir que
demain près faits même si c'est un très
bon préfet ou un sous préfet ou un haut
fonctionnaire de bercy aux affaires
sociales sera à même d'être un bon après
c'est l'heure personne ne peut le
garantir et tout le monde peut même en
douter voilà pourquoi madame la ministre
dans notre rapport nous présentons des
suggestions d'amendements de la réforme
etc avant tout nous souhaitons qu'elle
soit suspendue le temps d'organiser les
états généraux dont vous avez parlé
monsieur sénateurs vallini vous avez
voulu souligner que la voix de la france
est attendu je le crois aussi merci
également d'avoir souligné que le
ministère des affaires étrangères et un
ministère ouvert il est peut être plus
que d'autres je crois qu'il est bon que
ça se sache pour ma part j'ai voulu
peut-être vous souvenez-vous souligné
que dans la réforme il y avait également
des opportunités en termes plus à une
stratégie bien qu'ils aient des
mobilités en 30 mai qu'il aussi des
mobilités sortante qui n'est pas le
point fort que nous avons jusqu'ici
développé dans la culture de notre
ministère
la réforme permettra en réalité de
renforcer cette mobilité elle permettra
aux diplomates
et j'y serai attentif d'aller également
ailleurs et donc de rayonner de porter
un certain nombre de valeurs et de
donner peut-être plus de poids aux mines
et saint avertin étrangères dans
l'interministériel nous ne le faisons
pas assez nous sommes souvent
accueillons pour
des collègues nous avons besoin de leur
talent de leurs compétences mais nous
n'allons pas suffisamment rayonner à
l'extérieur de ce ministère aujourd'hui
il n'y a pas assez de diplomates dans
les préfectures dans les rectorats il ya
quelques uns avec les conseillers
diplomatiques des préfet et préfet de
région il a trop peu il y en a trop peu
dans les rectorats alors que j'ai
quelques j'avais je ne suis plus un
diplomate quelques excellents collègues
d'ambassadeurs qui sont des recteurs
deux d'entre eux en autriche et dans un
pays voisin dont il ya beaucoup
d'admiration qui sont trop fermé la
nôtre est ouverte elle doit bénéficier
grâce à cette réforme de la haute
fonction publique qui ne touche pas que
le quai d'orsay est loin de là d'un
certain de mobilité sortante et puis au
bout du bout que vous dire c'est
l'excellence des diplomates qui fera la
différence s'ils sont bons et sont
capables de le démontrer à l'extérieur
moi je ne suis pas inquiète dans leur
capacité à être accueillis ailleurs en
tout cas c'est une opportunité nouvelle
permise par la réforme qui n'existaient
pas précédemment le pouvoir de
nomination du chef de l'état nuit n'a
pas n'a pas été modifié et donc le cas
de figure que vous évoquez a toujours
été possible il reste il sera pour ce
qui concerne des agents diplomatiques de
moindre rang que le rang d'ambassadeur
encadré désormais davantage qu'il ne
l'est puisqu'il fera passer par ce
processus de d'un panel et de
vérification des compétences dernier
point le sénateur vous avez évoqué comme
les grévistes le font parfois la
suspension de cette réforme je vais être
honnête avec vous comme je les ai été
avec eux il ne saurait y avoir de
suspension de la réforme puisque la
réforme est achevée elle repose sur une
ordonnance et des décrets dont le décret
qui a fait beaucoup parler de lui qui
est celui du 16 avril c'est un paradoxe
d'ailleurs qu'il y fait parler autant de
lui en termes négatifs alors que c'est
lui qui inscrit dans notre ordre
réglementaire les garanties qu'ils ont
été obtenus par jean yves le drian
monsieur le sénateur sido sur le vote
des étrangers
des français partant à l'étranger il y a
eu des difficultés en chine c'est vrai
je m'en suis entretenu moi même avec mon
homologue chinois lors du premier
entretien que j'ai eue avec lui depuis
la situation s'est un tout petit peu
détendu mais il était anormal que nos
compatriotes ne puisse pas exercer leur
droit démocratique de vote je le lui dis
de la façon la plus claire pour le reste
nous avons une appréciation positive du
vote par internet le bilan est très
positif
non seulement aux yeux de la ministre
mais aux yeux des français qui en ont
bénéficié puisque nous avons eu notre
moyenne de 8,9 sur 10 lorsque nous avons
consulté nos compatriotes sur ce qu'il
pensait de ce dispositif qui était
nouveau alors qu'il connut quelques
quelques heures jeudi quelques heures
plus tôt que quelques ratés parce que
personne n'a pratiquement personne n'a
été empêché de voter les quelques
incidents techniques pendant la coupure
de réseau a été réparée au bout de
quelques heures ne s'est pas reproduite
pour le second tour nous n'avons eu
aucun incident technique ce qui est
assez remarquable pour une première
c'était une première et puis positif
aussi par le résultat qui l'a permis
vous avez bien voulu rappeler monsieur
le sénateur
les trois quarts et même plus des trois
quarts des suffrages qui sont qui se
sont exprimés grâce par les français et
étrangers ont été réalisés grâce à ce
vote électronique donc bilan positif ce
qui me permet de répondre à votre
dernière question oui nous songeons il
faudra vérifier si toutes les conditions
techniques sont réunis mais nous
songeons à développer le vote par
internet pour les différents scrutins
pour les français de l'étranger
mais ce sénateur que des skinny vous
avez parlé de l'afrique et de l'ukraine
sur
l'afrique la situation n'était pas
mauvaise mais la situation a évolué
lorsque nous sommes intervenus en 2013
je lis brièvement dans mon propos
liminaire nous sommes intervenus à la
demande du mali nous avons endigué la
progression terroriste ça ne fait aucun
doute la situation évolue et il y a eu
un double coup d'état il y a désormais
une
junte qui s'enferme sur elle-même et qui
ne doit sa survie
qu'à la présence de mercenaires
étrangers qui par ailleurs se manifeste
le plus par les exactions qui se
commettent que par leur talent à lutter
contre les groupes terroristes armés
il faut donc ré articulé c'était
indispensable dès lors que les autorités
fut-elle des autorités de fait considéré
que nous n'étions plus bienvenu au mali
je tiens à ajouter je les dis de façon
trop laconique tout à l'heure que leurs
articulations du dispositif français au
mali se passe bien et pour qu'il se
passe bien il faut que ça se passe en
coordination avec les forces armées
maliennes donc dans cette manoeuvre de
repli les choses se passent bien où tu
nous le calendrier nous espérons pouvoir
finir avant la fin de l'été en revanche
sur le plan politique très clairement un
joli diamant nos relations sont
particulièrement limitées avec la junte
malienne est nécessaire qu'il en soit
ainsi vous avez parlé de l'ukraine
nous avons
non seulement livré des césar qui font
la preuve de leur efficacité
jour après jour si vous le voyez sur les
réseaux sociaux qu utilise beaucoup les
autorités militaires ukrainienne mais
nous avons livré depuis le début des
équipements de protection nous allons
livrer des véhicules de l'avant blindé
permettant aux combattants ukrainien
d'aller au devant un plus plus plus en
sécurité nous livrons des munitions je
ne détaillerai pas ce qui a été fait
parce qu'il ne m'appartient pas de le
faire mais je vous rassure et ça n'est
évidemment pas uniquement la fourniture
des canons caesar 255 quels que soient
leur efficacité qui constitue l'axé
principal de notre effort nous livrons
des munitions parce que toutes les
missions sont tirés il faut les
remplacer et je voudrais vous rassurer
également il y à un processus de
coordination entre européens et d'une
façon générale entre alliés dans un
format qui est qui qui prend le nom de
rammstein parce que ça se déroule sur
cette base de ramstein même si ce n'est
pas l'otan qui coordonne mais les alliés
et européens qui se coordonnent entre
eux chacun fait ce sénateur à la hauteur
non seulement des demandes qu'il reçoit
et nous recevons régulièrement des
demandes très précises de la part des
autorités ukrainiennes mais la hauteur
de ses capacités et de façon coordonnée
madame la sénatrice carotti vous avez
parlé du mali du niger essentiellement
en regrettant que le pilier
développement n'est pas
était suffisamment développée
suffisamment efficace au mali
c'est vrai mais encore une fois il ya
une situation à laquelle nous avons dû
faire face ce n'est pas nous qui avance
et un un coup d'état ni un double coup
d'état qui a fait que les efforts qu'il
aurait fallu faire et qu'il aurait fallu
que les autorités de ce pays fasse elle
même avec notre aide n'ont pas été fait
ce qui conduit à la situation actuelle
l'éducation reste pour nous une priorité
l'éducation des jeunes filles
prioritairement l'aide alimentaire nous
avons pu signer un certain nombre
d'accord là dessus au niger donc c'est
ceci qui va constituer la nouvelle
politique africaine de la france en
complément des accords de sécurité de
défense lorsqu'il y en aura
vous avez parlé du criblage et je vais
vous répondre très vite un travail
énorme a été fait à votre demande et sur
le fondement de la loi du 4 août 2000 21
travail guidé par une seule volonté qui
est de faciliter le travail des ong pour
réduire le plus possible les obligations
de criblage des bénéficiaires finaux il
sera poursuivi merci président je vais
revenir rapidement sur le sur le mali
vous nous avez dit madame la ministre il
y avait une feuille de route qui était
envisagé donc au niger
rappelons-nous qui est une des coudes et
aux mauves au mali sans qu'une nous les
voyons venir comme ceux d'aujourd'hui
qui ont payé le prix du sang
et se retire avec un risque majeur c'est
que les attentats soient commis au
moment du retrait et avec les
conséquences mais sûr que cela peut
avoir
pensez vous que les moyens précédent et
actuel donné à la dgse au mali ont été
et sont suffisants
deuxième point s'agissant de la grande
bretagne
boris johnson a été remercié la relation
avec lui était très tumultueuse
pensez vous que son retrait peut être
bénéfique dans le cadre des relations
franco britanniques notamment avec les
conséquences d'une meilleure application
tout comme plus honnête de ce qui avait
été décidé au moment du du mexique
voilà simplement votre point de vue là
dessus
merci yannick olivier cadic c'est
monsieur le président madame la ministre
les membres du groupe union centriste se
réjouit sincèrement de votre nomination
et nous vous souhaitons une pleine
réussite dans l'accomplissement de
l'accomplissement de votre mission la
présidence française de l'union
européenne qui s'est achevé il y à trois
semaines a été remarquée et remarquable
nous voudrions saluer l'engagement de la
france et de l'union européenne en
faveur de l'ukraine et de son peuple
depuis le début de l'agression russe
vous avez mentionné l'adoption de
sanctions européennes
hier pour bloquer l'importation d'or en
provenance de russie depuis l'annexion
de la crimée par la russie en 2014 la
banque centrale de russie a plus que
doublé la part d'or dans ses réserves
elles sont passées de 8 9% à 21,7 pour
cent cela s'est fait au détriment de la
part des devises américaine et
européenne dans le même temps la russie
a passé des accords pour extraire de
l'or au soudan en république
centrafricaine et au mali le groupe
wagner cdu sévit de manière sinistre
dans ces trois pays avez vous prévu une
action diplomatique pour freiner
l'activité russe en matière minière avec
ces trois pays madame ministre vous avez
une fine connaissance du réseau
diplomatique et consulaire et
connaissait ces défis vous le démontrer
encore par vos propos suite à la réforme
du corps diplomatique vous avez rappelé
la perte de plus de 18% des effectifs du
ministère en 15 ans l'exercice
budgétaire fait souvent apparaître le
mystère de l'europe et des affaires
étrangères comme une simple structure de
coûts à maîtriser et à réduire on oublie
totalement les ressources engrangées
grâce à ses 2 tp un agent du service
vise a produit quatre fois plus de
revenus que son coût chacun de ces
agents fait gagner de l'argent à la
france à titre d'exemple parlons d'un
poste que vous connaissez parfaitement
londres 8 5 millions d'euros de revenus
en droits de chancellerie de visa en
2010 9 6 millions d'euros encaissés
depuis le début de l'année les consulats
ne doivent pas être vues comme des
structures de coûts mais plutôt comme
des structures de profits qu'il convient
de développer ils fournissent un service
public attendu par nos ressortissants
qui peine actuellement obtenir des
rendez-vous pour avoir ou faire
renouveler leur passeport je partage
votre avis sur l'action bénéfique de
votre prédécesseur jean yves le drian
qui a su mettre un terme à l'érosion des
moyens ces dernières années mais l'heure
est peut-être venue de revoir l'ensemble
du dispositif pour recréer un nouvel
élan que pensez vous de l'idée d'une loi
de programmation consulaire afin de
donner une nouvelle perspective à ce
réseau aux caisses questionnerait pas
sur la réforme du quai d'orsay comme
vous l'avez dit elle est passée quand
même par ordonnance le décret a été
publié le week-end de pâques je pense
qu'une meilleure concertation aurait
débouché sur un contenu peut-être plus
acceptables et acceptées par tout le
monde et ce n'est pas non plus sur les
français de l'étranger puisque je crois
que nous aurons l'occasion lors du débat
budgétaire en effet de vous présenter
des amendements ce que nous faisons
chaque année non pas pour être
désagréable avec le gouvernement et pour
montrer à chaque fois que vraiment ce
ministère
souffre terriblement depuis des années
en effet vous avez beau très bien décrit
la situation aujourd'hui et nous avons
besoin peut-être de plus de moyens ou
comme le dit
mon collègue olivier cadic qu'une
réflexion de fond à savoir en effet quel
sont les missions aujourd'hui qu'ils
reviennent aux diplomates et est-ce
qu'on peut continuer à augmenter leur
nombre tout en réduisant les moyens
financiers je voudrais simplement vous
poser une question sur l'afrique pour
revenir à votre déplacement au niger
avec votre collègue ministre de la
défense je crois que le président du
niger en effet fait preuve d'une grande
lucidité quant aux problèmes
sécuritaires de son pays n'est pas le
seul
je crois que c'est toute cette partie de
l'afrique aujourd'hui qui est son
souffrance et c'est vrai que si en effet
nous avons besoin d'une politique 3d
plus équilibrée en matière de
développement il me semble qu'il ya un
élément pernicieux auxquelles nous
devons répondre et je ne sais pas si
votre ministère en tout cas il en est
pas équipé aujourd'hui ne devraient pas
mener une réflexion et voir comment nous
pouvons répondre à la propagande anti
française celle ci aujourd'hui touche
par les réseaux sociaux une population
jeune
à laquelle nous ne savons pas répondre
nous
n'avons pas nous ne sommes pas équipés
en tout cas les les ambassadeurs ne le
sont pas en poste
de pouvoir répondre rapidement et
utilement à celle ci et nous sommes
toujours en décalage dont je pense que
nous avons vraiment besoin aujourd'hui
de nous équiper peut-être y avez-vous
déjà réfléchi peut-être que le ministère
a une cellule en place que nous ne
connaissons pas mais il faut vraiment
agir sur ce plan là parce que je crois
que nous sommes en train de perdre une
grande partie de la population sur le
royaume uni
est ce que
le retrait de boris johnson
non encore effective bénéficiera à nos
relations
gens forment le jeu est évidemment un
jeu veulent espérer il m'est même arrivé
je crois dans formé le voeu publiquement
en soulignant que ce serait nécessaire
que c'est possible parce que la
situation actuelle ne permet pas à nos
pays d'assumer le rôle à la hauteur de
ce que doit être leur responsabilité
dans le monde est-ce que ce voeu sera
exaucé je ne saurais le dire puisque
nous sommes pour le moment que dans une
phase préparatoire à la succession de
monsieur johnson qui est la phase d'une
campagne électorale
menée au sein du parti conservateur avec
un premier temps
au sein des députés actuellement élu et
que ça se prête plus le semble-t-il à la
surenchère qu'est la construction de
meilleures relations avec l'union
européenne ou avec la france donc il
faut attendre le second temps pour que
je puisse vous répondre monsieur center
cadic sur les
manoeuvres
russe pour
s'implanter plus durablement en afrique
nous les voyons nous les dénonçons je
crois que la france est l'un des pays
qui a été le plus clair à ce sujet y
compris pour éclairer peut-être un
certain nombre de nos partenaires voire
même voire même certains partenaires
africains pour que les sirènes ne chante
pas trop doucement à leurs oreilles pour
ce qui concerne
l'eau je reviendrai vers vous parce que
je ne sais pas ce qui a été fait ou ce
qui peut être fait dans des
circonstances où
les milices de wagner agissent comme des
prédateurs
sur les questions de nos consulats
merci d'avoir souligné ce qu'a porté le
ministère je ne le vois pas comme soul
taux de profit ne sommes pas encore d'un
secteur privé mais normand et du monde
souligné que la diplomatie ne coûte pas
tout chaud parfois même elles rapportent
il en va de même des consulats et puis
nous assurerons avant tout le service
public que nous devons assurer pour les
français qui vivent à l'étranger ou qui
souhaitent passage alors une loi de
programmation consulaires pourquoi pas
nous verrons ce que donnent les les
états généraux les réflexions que nous
mènerons cet automne donc je ne veux pas
préjuger de leur résultat je suis
ouverte à toute option on peut
regarder avec le tentation en tout cas
avec envie les joies de programmation
qui existent dans le domaine militaire
qui sont promises dans le domaine de la
justice
donc pourquoi pas en matière consulaires
et diplomatiques je crois que s'il
devait y en avoir il ne faudrait pas la
limiter au champ consulaires tout en
soulignant le sénateur vous le savez que
dans le retard qui a été pris par nombre
de nos ambassades et consulats une
partie dû au sous-effectif et une partie
nu tout simplement à la pandémie qui
nous a conduit à réduire la voilure
pendant les moments de confinement ils
ont été nombreux et est long pour ce qui
concerne le royaume uni
ce center vous avez posé la question du
du mouvement est observé à juste titre
que nous sommes d'ores et déjà le
19 juillet
croyez bien que j'ai travaillé sans
relâche depuis le premier jour je dis
monsieur depuis le premier jour avec
début juin quelques nominations qui ont
pu qui ont pu passer et depuis parce que
ces nominations de formation en conseil
des ministres ont donc l'accord non
seulement du gouvernement mais du
président de la république est
nécessaire du travail préparatoire qui a
été fait qu'il n'a pas encore pu aboutir
mais j'espère que demain si vous m'aviez
interrogé demain ma réponse aurait pu
être différente et peut-être est
peut-être la semaine suisse ce serait
bien qu'on en prenne connaissance
on ne peut pas le faire donc que les
agréments n'ont pas été dévoilés par des
pillages concernés mais j'espère que
demain il y aura une preuve de
l'accélération nos territoires
ultramarins sont un élément important de
la puissance de la france dans la région
nous avons des territoires nous avons
des hommes nous avons une présence
militaire également nous avons la
deuxième zone économique exclusive au
monde grâce à ses territoires et je
souhaite pendant que j'exercerai ma
mission que nous articulons mieux
les enjeux qui concernent
mon collègue ministre de l'intérieur qui
est en charge également des autres
maires et les enjeux de la diplomatie il
ya un continuum évident qu'il faut
retrouver et donc notre présence dans
l'inde au pacifique puisqu'elle passe
par nos propres territoires en grande
partie et pas seulement par l'action
diplomatique de la france dans la région
il faut mieux les combinés on a commencé
de le faire un sens sans attendre
que je viens au gouvernement puisque le
sommet
u12 pacifique qui s'est tenue sous
présidence française au début de l'année
a permis de faire mieux prendre
conscience qu'il ya là des enjeux qui
dépassent même les enjeux pour notre
pays madame risk and memory merci
également de ce que vous avez dit comme
olivier cadic comme d'autres sur la
façon dont nos agents assument leurs
missions et leurs missions croissante il
faut une réflexion de fond c'est tout à
fait certain sur non seulement
l'adaptation de ses missions et de nos
moyens mais sur la place de la
diplomatie dans l'état quelles sont les
missions qu'on juge prioritaire nous ne
pouvons pas les définir nous mêmes à nos
autorités politiques au delà de ce
ministère devront également nous fixer
une ligne de conduite sur le
niger et au delà sur sur la sous région
en cas mendient en afrique comment
répondre à la propagande anti française
et la propagande anti occidental qui est
à l'oeuvre que l'on joue en est
évidemment dans tous ses effets néfastes
qui est une propagande d'autant plus
efficace qu'elle un petit peu de monde
coûte très peu cher passe
essentiellement par les réseaux sociaux
pas seulement pour un certain nombre de
radios aussi et pour y faire face nous
n'étions pas équipés
parce que ça n'est pas notre façon de
faire parce que nous sommes les pays
démocratiques parce que nous ne
pratiquons pas la falsification de
l'information des manipulations
mensongère d'autres que nous
une spécialité à ce titre mais c'est un
autre honneur de ne pas le faire
néanmoins il faut contrer cette
propagande et la contrer plus
efficacement dos le faisant c'est
l'objet de réflexions qui ont déjà été
engagés au sein de ministères que je
poursuivrai et avec là aussi besoin
de moyens dans les demandes
budgétaires qui ont été présentées par
les ministères de l'europe et des
affaires étrangères en faire ses plus
hautes autorités il y à celle ci nous
devons avoir un minimum de moyens et
qu'on prive de moyens humains pour avoir
un dispositif de lutte contre la
désinformation
au sein d'autres ministères mais aussi
avec une dimension interministérielle
indispensable mais sur des armées sera
mis en contribution d'autres services
aussi une école duranton merci monsieur
le président madame la ministre merci
pour vos propos liminaire vous avez
souligné donc que dans votre propos
liminaire l'importance politique de
l'adhésion de la suède et de la finlande
à l'otan donc cela va renforcer notre
sécurité collective et renforcer la
place des européens au sein de l'otan
donc la signature des protocoles
d'adhésion par les ambassadeurs des 30
pays membres donc a ouvert le 5 juillet
donc au siège de l'alliance atlantique à
bruxelles le processus de ratification
donc la signature des protocoles
d'adhésion accorde le statut de pays
invité à la suède et à la finlande mais
elles ne bénéficieront pas de la
protection de l'article 5 de la charte
de l'otan en cas d'attaqué tant que les
et 30 états membres n'auront pas ratifié
donc leur adhésion dans quel degré de
protection l'europe peut-elle d'ores et
déjà assurée à la suède et à la finlande
sur le plan militaire en cas d'agression
donc sur leur territoire ou à proximité
immédiate donc le président r douanes à
nouveau menacé hier donc de geler
l'adhésion de ces deux pays s'ils ne
prennent pas part donc est la lutte
contre le terrorisme
il souhaite l'extradition donc de 3,33
militants donc appartenant une sorte 33
militants kurdes pardon appartenant donc
aux mouvements du pkk pensez vous que la
prise de position du président turc donc
sur l'accession de la suède et de la
finlande à l'otan puisse constituer un
ralentisseur à même de différer
lourdement ces deux adhésions et enfin
donc au sommet madrid vous avez eu un
entretien avec le secrétaire général de
lotus de l'onu donc cet entretien a
permis de souligner la force de
l'engagement de la france au sein de
l'alliance atlantique dont le rôle
central est encore souligné par
l'agression donc de la russie contre le
cren vous avez mis en avant le
renforcement de la contribution
française à la posture de défense et de
dissuasion sur le flanc oriental donc
quelles sont les prochaines étapes du
renforcement de la contribution
française à la posture de défense et de
dissuation sur le front oriental je
remercie
merci nicole gisèle jourda merci
monsieur le congrès ce sens sur les
sujets affaires étrangères s'il vous
plaît
car demain nous avons fait défense
madame
madame la ministre
merci donc des propos que vous avez
tenus d éclairage que nous avait donné
depuis que cette audition moi je
souhaiterais vous faire préciser un
point que vous avez évoquées et sur
lequel on peut passer rapidement mais
qui à mon sens c'est un point
fondamental
vous avez dit donc aujourd'hui l'ukraine
et la moldavie avait statut de candidat
pour rentrer dans l'europe donc je
voudrais vous qu'avez-vous les
politiques de voisinage et de
partenariat oriental et surtout le pays
qui quasiment conjointement en tout cas
dans la foulée avait déposé sa demande
d'adhésion à savoir la géorgie
qui donc depuis 2014 et 2016 est en
contrat d'association avec l'union
européenne et qui compte tenu des deux
conflits gelés avec l'os et il a quasi
dont est quand même fort marri de
de voir que sur ces trois demandes
d'adhésion deux ont été retenus u ne l'a
pas été donc je souhaitais vous avez
évoqué madame la ministre la notion de
communauté politique européenne or la
géorgie par exemple d'apporter aussi au
conseil de l'europe alors est-ce que
quel gage peut-on donner parce que pour
suivre les questions de partenariat
oriental madame la ministre et
poursuivre les trois accords en ukraine
moldavie et géorgie au gré des aléas
politiques subi par ces pays et des
alternances politiques il est évident
que aux yeux des contrats d'association
à la fois il ya des progressions mais il
ya aussi quelquefois des régressions et
je dois avouer que c'est pas totalement
lisible et compréhensible et je
souhaiterais donc à voir donc votre
point de vue sur cette question d'autant
plus que madame la pl pour la présidente
de géorgie est une ancienne de vos
concerts et elle a donc à main donc ce
pays ce qui n'est pas compte tenu de la
situation une sinécure donc quelles sont
les perspectives et comment envisagez
vous les relations avec la géorgie enfin
joël guerriau mais l'âme
merci beaucoup madame la ministre je ne
reviendrai pas sur la réforme du corps
diplomatique je voudrais simplement dire
que depuis 1988 que je suis élu des
français de grande bretagne et d'irlande
sénatrice depuis 2004 je n'ai jamais
douté une seconde je peux attester de
l'immense qualité du personnel
diplomatique
jamais il n'a manqué à la france et je
peux vous dire qu'il fait l'admiration
de tous les pays et trancher je voulais
par contre vous interroger sur un
problème de communication
pas seulement vis-à-vis des peuples
africains où elle est importante bien
sûr mais aussi au sein même de notre
alliance euro atlantique je dois dire
que j'ai été assez scandalisé ce matin
en découvrant dans le magazine pourtant
très respectable doubleuse mais
atlantique
une intervention une interview de
l'ancien premier ministre du danemark et
ancien secrétaire général de l'otan
anders fogh rasmussen qui attaquaient la
france en dix ans que la france n'avait
quasiment rien livré en ukraine et nous
comparons avec les autres pays disant
par exemple que l'allemagne avait fait
dix fois plus alors qu'il ne s'agit que
de promesses alors mesdames les
ministres ce type d'argument est assez
lamentable
bien sûr nous savons nous n'avons pas pu
faire autant que les états unis par
exemple
bien sûr nous ne faisons pas de
promesses nous nous faisons nous avons
des actes mais je crois qu'il sera
important de rappeler à nos partenaires
qu'il faudrait un petit peu plus de
dignité et de solidarité et rappelait
aussi ce que nous faisons ce que nous
avons fait par exemple en afrique et
dernière petite chose aussi enfin petite
chose qui ne l'est pas est ce que vous
pourriez nous dire quelques mots
peut-être sur le protocole
nord-irlandais l'adhésion de la suède
manas la sénatrice et de la finlande à
l'otan vous avez raison il n'y a pas de
protection au titre de légende
atlantique tant que le processus de
ratification n'est pas achevé qu'y at il
eh bien le présenter république l'a
rappelé je vous le rappelle également
volontiers la clause d'assistance
mutuelle qui est à peu près l'équivalent
entre états membres de l'union
européenne
c'est le cas de la suède et c'est le cas
de la finlande
donc le fameux article 42 7 que nous
avons rappelé
tout récemment
lorsqu'il s'est agi pour la suède et
pour la finlande avant madrid de faire
part de leur souhait de rejoindre
l'alliance atlantique dans cet
intervalle et bien il y à une protection
de ces deux pays par le canal de l'union
européenne et ses états membres votre
autre question portait sur le attitude
du président r doan et les difficultés
qui pourrait être anticipé dans la
ratification par la turquie de ces deux
protocoles
d'abord
l'accord fait l'objet d'un texte écrit
donc il s'agira pas pour les uns pour
les autres de s'écarter de ce qui a été
convenu c'est une évidence mais je dois
à la rappeler néanmoins au delà de ça je
suis convaincu que pour avancer le
meilleur moyen
est de poursuivre les uns des autres
nous ratification d'ores et déjà la
moitié des états membres je crois ont
achevé le processus de ratification et
c'est la raison pour laquelle je me 2 je
me permettrai
dès cette semaine et bientôt devant
l'assemblée nationale de vous rappeler
combien notre sécurité collective
gagnera à la présence dans les gens'
atlantique de la suède et de la finlande
et le gazon sur le flanc oriental qui
concerne davantage je crois ce président
mes collègues de la défense même si je
vous rappelle volontiers que la france
est présente sur le flanc oriental en
tant que nation cadre en roumanie et
qu'elle a décidé de renforcer
après le sommet de madrid et l'annoncé
sommet de madrid
le sa posture sur place elle est
présente également en estonie ont
maintenu notre dispositif elle contribue
aussi à la surveillance aérienne et
maritime de l'espace
considérer
une question était posée sur
[Musique]
la différence de traitement entre
l'ukraine et
la moldavie d'une part et la géorgie
d'autre part madame la sénatrice si la
géorgie a été traité de façon différente
c'est parce que il est résulté de
l'examen fait par la commission qui dont
nous avons suivi la vie mais qui a fait
son examen de ces candidatures selon les
critères habituels d'examen d'une
candidature la commission a conclu que
la situation de la géorgie aussi bien sa
situation sur le plan économique que sur
le plan des réformes que celui l'état de
droit encore et un tota métier pour sa
présidente qui était non seulement une
collègue mais qui demeure une amie si
vous me permettez de le dire la
situation n'était pas la même que celle
de la moldavie et de l'ukraine et donc
ne permettait pas d'envisager maintenant
l'octroi du statut de candidat je veux
appeler votre attention madame la
sénatrice sur le fait qu'il y ait eu
néanmoins un progrès important pour l'ag
engine qui a été accompli au moment de
ce conseil européen des 23 et 24 juin
puisque désormais la perspective
européenne la perspective européenne est
reconnue à la géorgie ce qui n'était pas
le cas jusqu'ici
mais ce sénateur laurent vous avez parlé
de plusieurs questions qui ont trait au
proche orient en quelques mots parce que
on pourrait évidemment être
plus long et plus détaillées sur ce
sujet important la question
palestinienne demeure au centre
évidemment des difficultés
tant que la solution à deux états ne
sera pas mise en oeuvre il est douteux
que les tensions puisse cesser nous
encourageons et nous accueillons
volontiers toutes ces entreprises
normalisation qu'ils sentent qu'ils sont
en cours depuis quelques temps
maintenant qu'on appelle les accords
d'abraham ils sont bienvenus pour autant
ils ne permettent pas de traiter la
question de fond quel est question
palestinienne il faut poursuivre le
présent de la république l'a dit avec
celui qui fut mon homologue mais qui est
devenu premier ministre par intérim
monsieur yaïr lapid je lui avais dit moi
même lorsqu'il était mon homologue il
fait partie de ceux en israël qui
considère que la solution à deux états
est nécessaire
par ailleurs nous avons des contacts
étroits avec l'autorité palestinienne
je me suis entretenu la semaine dernière
avec mon homologue palestinien al malki
dans la perspective de la visite du
président abbas cette semaine demain à
paris pour regarder comment
restaurer un horizon en politique celui
qui manque tellement en ce moment et ne
peut qu'alimenter des frustrations et
des incompréhensions d'un région la
visite du président biden
a eu des éléments
évidemment positif je veux les saluer
comme nous l'avons fait officiellement
aussi bien pour l'aide aux palestiniens
puisque des avancées ont été
enregistrées avec une aide de 100
millions de dollars au profit jérusalem
est et de 200 millions de dollars pour
l'une rats c'est une bonne chose la
france elle même bien sûr contribuer à
l'inra des
éléments positifs aussi à saluer vers
une relation plus normale
entre israël et l'arabie saoudite suit
cette visite l'espace aérien saoudien et
ont rouvert mais il est certain je crois
que nous serons d'accord sur le fait
qu'il faut poursuivre sa dynamique qu'il
y a encore beaucoup de marge de
progression qu'il faudrait en termes
clairs faire davantage et se fixer des
objectifs plus ambitieux je reviens la
nécessité d'une perspective politique
seul à même de régler le conflit israélo
palestinien est de faire baisser les
tensions qui sont en train de monter qui
nous préoccupe madame la sénatrice
garriaud-maylam
merci des appréciations élogieuses que
vous avez bien voulu porter sur notre
ministère est sur le travail de ses
agents
sur les armes françaises en ukraine jeu
j'assume totalement bien évidemment la
politique qui est celle du gouvernement
français par opposition à d'autres que
vous connaissez comme moi et comme le
sénateur cadic vous penserez à un pays
en particulier
qui consiste à faire plus khadir puis
faire donc nous ne disons pas tout ce
que nous faisons nous avons répondu
depuis le mois de février
à différentes demandes elles sont
nombreuses qui nous ont été présentées
par les autorités ukrainiennes nous le
faisons à la hauteur de nos capacités
il y à des tensions sur un terrain
nombre de matériels des difficultés à en
livrer trop mais nous faisons beaucoup
plus de choses que ces fameux canons
caesar
dont on parle et c'est
tout à fait volontiers que nous en
parlons nous mêmes mais il n'ya pas que
ça il n'est pas nécessaire de livrer
trop d'informations confidentielles à
l'autre belligérant je vous demande de
bien vouloir le comprendre enfin sur le
protocole nord-irlandais sujet dont nous
parlions parlait beaucoup la réaction
unanime des états membres de l'union
européenne et de la commission a été
mesurée et est fondée ce sont des
comportements qui sont inadmissibles et
à 2 amis et démocratique ne peut pas
envisager de mesures unilatérales
violent ses propres engagements et
violent un traité international nous
l'avons dit publiquement je lui dis moi
mais ma liste rose lorsqu'elle est venue
me voir à paris il faudra le rappeler si
c'était nécessaire au prochain premier
ministre britannique
[Musique]